if you want to learn a little bit
about how to read your thyroid lab reports
go get yours
I'll wait
just a little history
little background
my history is that of thyroid cancers
WHO I do not have a thyroid gland
but if you do
this can apply to you too
I had to type them up
like this
because my lab results were all mixed up
let's start with the first two numbers
the tsh and the total t four
this might be the only thing
that you have in your lab reports
that is because it seems that
most conventional wisdom tells us
and they tell their patients
that they don't need to know anything else
other than that
that is so wrong
I have a suppressed tsh
because of the cancer
but my number is 0. one nine
and you can see the normal range
right to the right of that is 0.4 to 4.5
the higher you get to 4.5
or Beyond that
probably the worst
you feel functionally speaking
most people feel their best between 05 and 15
I don't even pay attention to total t4
so then I go on to free t
four and mine was 1.5
and the range is eight
or 0.8 to 1.8
so you should be in the top half of that
and that is where people are going to feel
the best now
if you're Lucky to have a free t three
reading this will help you out a lot
so mine is a 3.4
the high end of the range is a 4.2
and it's best to be in that upper quarter
of the range
to feel your best
some people can go above that range
and feel just fine
I don't really pay attention to total t three
either now
reverse t three
you can see that
this shows that it's in the normal range
I can almost guarantee if you're only seeing
conventional doctors
you probably do not have this number
so reverse t three is the storage
form of the active thyroid hormone
and actually blocks the receptors
on your cells
to receive thyroid hormone
so if you have elevated reverse t three
you need to do some changing up
and I'll tell you what
I'm doing
the normal range
for reverse t three is eight to 25
I'm at 19
ideally functionally
you should be below 12
so I have some work to do on that
the tpo antibody
for some reason
they didn't draw the other antibody this time
but it's low normal
and there's really been nothing to see on that
for me for me
my plan is to lower my t four dose
so currently
I take hundred
seventy five micrograms
I'm lowering that to 150 micrograms
and then I'm upping my t three dose
so that that reverse t3 can come down
because the only thing that makes reverse t3
along with stress and poor diet
and that kind of thing is
too much t4
t4 gets converted into t3
if it's not getting into the cells
it's stored as reverse t3
so by lowering my intake of medications for t4
we should lower that
and I should start feeling better in no time
part Ⅱ on thyroid labs coming up